first the race to space was just about
getting there now it's about getting a
lot of people or a lot of heavy
equipment off our planet at once
at least it is for SpaceX CEO Elon Musk
Starship is supposed to be the largest
vehicle ever sent to space
standing at 120 meters in stainless
steel it's designed to propel 100 people
for more than 100 tons of equipment to
orbit and musk is the only space
entrepreneur making that bet
he says it could Ferry passengers around
the world in half an hour but he says
his ultimate Vision to colonize Mars is
built on ideals
life can't just be about solving
problems they have to be things that
inspire you and going out there and
become being a multi-planet species and
being a space-faring civilization and
making science fiction not fiction
forever
I think that's one of those things
musk has had a tough year Tesla his
electric car company is facing
competition in a sector it used to
dominate and after paying 44 billion
dollars for Twitter in October he told
employees in March the company is now
worth half that but in just a decade
SpaceX has proven that Rockets once
thought disposable can be safely reused
getting Starship to the launch pad has
not been cheap in 2020 and 21 early
versions performed spectacular flips and
plunges over the swamps of southern
Texas but exploded on Landing the other
way of viewing this is that this is just
an experiment like we're going to do
this and then see if this is a
possibility of a market but if you can
treat a 100 million dollar rocket as an
experiment
there's a lot of things that you can
consider experiments the bigger question
is how or why such a craft would ever be
used we don't have any of the systems in
place on how to handle that sort of
volume of people what that social
organization would look like I would say
that when it comes to thinking about you
know Starship and what the future might
bring for it just because we can build a
rocket doesn't mean that we can build a
civilization musk who has celebrated
previous failures said the first test
was always a 50 50 bet a safe prediction
Colin Baker Al Jazeera which we referred